c'est non non c'est simple un tribunal
d'antan par un sonar et jugé qu'ils
condamnent les blessures gaillard
avec une part d'innocence tout le monde
nous allons sûrement
c'est ça
pas question de manquer ou non à moyens
son souvenir est nominé à frévent et le
fils les landais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est fini l'idole des jeunes vous
m'aviez dit tout à l'heure je chantais
passé j'aime mieux les pruneaux à jamais
l'esprit de rien c'est partout jour en
quote l'audience ait repris je vous
rappelle que nous jugeons aujourd'hui
inies de la fressange qui est inculpé
d'infraction sur l'affichage public
d'outragé aux moeurs d'homicide par
imprudence de crimes de guerre et
d'apologie du racisme
maintenant à se dresser devant où le
spectre de la société française
le procureur général de la république
des proches française
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le brigadier n'empêche à mon fils est un
magnifique et tout qu'est ce qu'ils ont
vécu
je ne vois pas le rapport avec la
qualifiée française français belges
belle rouquine rouquin coquine qu'aucun
mesquine mesquin ville brooklyn
vilebrequin mannequine mannequin monde
massif central monsieur l'avocat le plus
bas dans t'es tu n'auras pas faire les
vosges un jour plus tôt c'est trop petit
messi parce qu'il ya le ballon de
guebwiller c'est pour ça mesdames et
messieurs les jurés public chéri mon
amour bonjour ma colère salut ma hargne
et mon courroux
[Musique]
les hommes naissent tous libres et égaux
en droits comme pardonne mais cite une
phrase que j'ai beaucoup de mal à dire
sans rire les hommes naissent tous
libres et égaux en droits
prenons cette femme c'est une image
madame loin de moi l'idée de vous
prendre ici dans ce box trop exigu pour
les 180 cm de splendeur nacré qui
composent en tout bien tout honneur
votre principale source de revenus
prenons cette femme elle est belle la
beauté existe-t-il au monde
un privilège plus totalement exorbitants
que la beauté par sa beauté cette femme
n'est-elle pas un petit peu plus libre
et un petit peu plus égales dans le
grand combat pour survivre que la
moyenne des homo sapiens qui passent
leur vie à secourir après l'accueil en
attendant la mort qu'elle profond d'un
v6 il aurait l'outrecuidance de soutenir
au nom des grands principes
révolutionnaires que l'immonde boudin
trapu qui m'a collé une contredanse tout
à l'heure possède les mêmes armes pour
asseoir son bonheur terrestre que cette
grande fille felino mille charme trouble
où l'oeil se poser chancel avec une
bienveillante lubricité contenu
difficilement contenue
[Applaudissements]
quand on a vu mieux mesdames canton à
votre bouche votre grain de peau la
légèreté diaphane de votre démarche et
la longueur émouvante de vos cuisses
c'est une banalité de dire qu'on peut
facilement traverser l'existence à
l'abri des cabas trop lourd gorgé de
poireaux à l'écart de l'uniforme de
contractuels est bien loin de la
banquette en skaï du coin du fond de la
salle de bal où le triste l'aideront la
cne dans l'ombre cachant dans sa main
triste et grise le bout de son nez trop
fort transit dans sa semi laideur
commune embourbé dans sa cellulite
ordinaire engoncé dans ses complexes
d'infériorité ne sait que répondre aux
valseurs qui l'invitent je peux pas je
garde le sac à ma copine est encore le
boudin qu'on ne souffre pas médias le
boudin pas qu'on le boudin avec une
sensibilité suraigu le boudin qui est
beau du dedans le boudin qui a dans sa
tête et dans son coeur sa beauté
prisonnière comme ces gens du nord de la
chanson o qui ont dans les yeux le bleu
qui manque à leur décor pourtant
pourtant dieu me tripote merci mon dieu
la différence est mince entre une beauté
et un boudin quelques centimètres de
plus ou de moins en long en large
quelques millimètres de plus ou moins
entre les deux yeux quelques rondeurs ou
aspérités en plus ou en moins par ci par
là autour des hanches ou dans le corsage
des détails et ses détails près quelle
différence y at-il entre inès de la
fressange star à froufrous pour
remplumer saturé d'or du gotha et yvette
le crochard tourneuse précieuses sur
machines outils dans la seine saint
denis à y regarder de plus près elles
sont étonnamment semblables elle possède
l'une et l'autre le même nombre de faits
c'est le même nombre de saints les
longueurs s'ajouter de leur intestin
grêle et de leurs gros intestin à taille
approximativement 8 mètres et demi une
fois déplié est tiré
l'une et l'autre affiche au thermomètre
annales une température moyenne de 37
degrés 2 et le corps de l'une comme le
corps de l'autre contient grosso modo
70% d'eau et 30% de viandes diverses
dont certaines sous l'impulsion
salutaire d'influx nerveux varier leur
permettent aux choix de jouer des coudes
de cligner de l'oeil d'attraper
l'autobus voire de baisser leur culotte
sans le secours des voisins en cas
d'urgence uro génital
j'espère que je ne vous choque pas
madame vous auriez tort d'être choqués
d'après une étude approfondie effectuée
récemment par mes soins auprès des
familiers du tout hollywood des années
je suis en mesure d'affirmer aujourd'hui
que même marilyn monroe
aussi surprenant que cela paraisse même
marilyn monroe faisait pipi
ainsi il est vrai que les similitudes
l'emportent sur les dissemblances entre
deux êtres humains l'âge lui-même n'est
rien sherin est ce si ce n'est que selon
toute probabilité les asticots auront
fini de picorer la guêpière de ma
grand-mère quand ils entameront votre le
team robe du soir
pour le reste tenez j'étais invité la
semaine dernière à la soirée annuelle
des les anciennes miss france dont je
suis depuis longtemps l'un team pour
avoir été maintes fois juge de touche
pendant les compétitions
lors du dîner inaugural j'étais assis
entre miss france 1923 mr en 1982
le monde est un éternel recommencement
pensais-je avec un sens suraigu du lieu
commun tandis que comme pour me donner
raison la première me baser dessus
tandis que je bavais sur la seconde tout
fier encore de sa récente couronne miss
france 82 ne résista pas au plaisir de
nous rappeler son score 95 60 95 moins
d'émissions 11 23 les 60 60 60
moi aussi dur ego qui passait par là
entre l'avocat et la vinaigrette
moi aussi c'est 60 60 60
quelquefois ajouta-t-il de cette
inimitable voix de castrat transpyrénéen
qui charma plus d'une fille de salle
punk des bas-fonds de lisbonne au
carnaval annuel des morues dessalée pdp
des toits même pourquoi tu dis p des
domaines c'est pour gagner du temps
je t'ai prierai d'être assez aimable
pour préciser sa pensée je suis un jour
généralement quand je fais allusion à la
morue au portugal tu dis ta gueule [ __ ] et
là je dis [ __ ] toi même pour que nous ne
nous fasse pas de perdre du temps en 10
ans ta gueule pdp des domaines
[Applaudissements]
errare portugal home est pauvre pouf moi
aussi dit donc créé gommer mensurations
ses 60 60 60
quelquefois ajouta-t-il de sa
chaleureuse voix de gorge lourde de
sensualité visite quelquefois je fais 60
60 85 60 notamment quand je pense à
fernande l'ex-sagem du président
assez méditerranéen les gens du sud ont
dans les yeux le gland qui manque à leur
décor oui chers inès de la fressange
vous n'êtes finalement qu'une femme
comme les autres avec les mêmes raisons
que les autres de croire en dieu ou de
boire contrexéville
vous êtes donc aussi coupable que les
autres ce dont votre avocat va
d'ailleurs vous convaincre dans un
instant bien mieux que je n'ai su le
faire cependant
cependant avant de lui céder la parole
qui me soit permis vous dévorant de tous
mes yeux de vous resservir madame en
hommage à votre exquise beauté la
bouleversante déclaration qui fit un
jour le cardinal de richelieu à la très
belle très jeune et très pulpeuse
comtesse poli dans l'état qu'on avait
placés et son côté lors d'un dîner d'un
team à la cour de louis xiii
madame si ma robe était de bronze vous
entendriez sonner le tocsin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
etonnant non
[Musique]